what's your typical day like when you're
in production or or the writing phase
what's your typical day well writing i
think is very different than being in
the production side of it writing i like
to do a nine-to-five like usually 11 to
eight like I'm not I like to structure
my days so that I'm writing it like an
office job which is kind of funny in a
way because you kind of do this job
because you don't like the office job
but I like that kind of structure
because I like to be able to have an end
point for relaxation it doesn't always
work that way but like relaxation
meeting like watching movies or just
like thinking about something else other
than project because I think that's so
important just to stay like in life as
well so yeah I'll get up and I'll you
know sit in front of my computer not
writing for a couple of hours then write
something maybe then go make some lunch
and come back and not write something
for a while and then go back you know
and then you just kind of start and stop
like any job and just do that
consistently though but you know five
days a week for sure and in production
noce like just nothing just like no
sleep no no no emails no Twitter no like
nothing other than just the total
immersion in in the project there's just
literally no I mean maybe down the line
if there's multiple zeros added to
budgets and you have you know help maybe
there's it's possible to kind of have
like a life I've heard these like
stories that leg lars von trier like
ends up for and they all have dinner and
everything and that sounds lovely but I
can't picture it so there's always
problems to be solving or you know
there's always you know you're just just
in it for for production I think you're
just completely in that world and only
in that world
you